welcome back to Little Rock Stars it's
me Mt and the Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 actor Dave Bautista has just
confirmed that his upcoming Guardians of
the Galaxy movie will be his last
appearance in the MCU meaning that most
likely we could be seeing the demise of
our favorite invisible destroyer in
James Gunn's final emotional roller
coaster of a Marvel movie but what could
be most likely reason for the death of
draxxa destroyer in volume 3. well I
have a feeling that something within
Drax of the destroyer's biology could
hold an important key ingredient that
the high evolutionary needs for his
experimentations a key ingredient that
was sneakily given to Drax in a past
Guardians movie that will lead to his
Ultimate Death so stick with me while I
speculate speculation Nation because
Drax might be destroyed by one purple
man named Herbert Windham the high
evolutionary himself but of course like
always do not forget to hit up the
rockstarsmerch.com so you can buy one of
her cool shirts hoodies stickers pins
all of our amazing dope ass nerd options
over there and it's a great way to
support the channel so head on over to
new roxasmerch.com today but alright
gang recently in an interview with GQ
Magazine Dave Bautista said that while
he's super grateful to play the world of
Drax throughout all these years his time
as the character will be over very soon
pretty much confirming that something
major is going to happen to his
character in Guardians 3 that will take
his specific iteration of Drax the
Destroyer out of the MCU as a major
player for at least a very long time if
not forever because that's usually how
James go to Rose those movies people
don't usually come back but here's the
thing guys Drax the Destroyer is an
insanely durable bald being with thick
skin much like myself and we saw this
demonstrated the best recently in the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
when homeboy just took several bullets
to the chest and just laughed it off
but then again Drax does have famously
sensitive nipples I have sensitive
nipples so those trigger happy cops
really should have known better and of
course we cannot forget but during
Guardians 2 Drax was also famously able
to survive being dangled behind a
crashing ship as his body crashed into a
bunch of trees on its way down for some
odd reason directs The Destroyer is a
super powered alien who can take a
turkishly insane amount of damage but
that is not the only reason why the high
evolutionary would be interested in
experimenting on this Drexel Destroyer
fellow because much like I theorized in
a past video about how I believe the
high evolutionary is attempting to make
the highly evolved and nine Unstoppable
tentacled Cosmic being known as superego
I think that Herbert Windham will be
secretly using the biological material
that the collector's organization mined
from nowhere combined with whatever
remains of star-lord's celestial father
ego the living planet after baby Bruce
blew up ego's brain with a harbulary
energy Evolution bomb now if you
remember the reason why the collector
was even at nowhere in the first place
was to mine and sell all of nowhere's
brain tissue and spinal fluid on the
galactic black market however after
draxxa Destroyer foolishly calls Ronan
the Accuser to fight him on nowhere
Ronan beats Drax unconscious and then
throws Drax into a tub of what appears
to be Celestial spinal fluid the same
type of celestial fluid and energy that
was coursing through the bones of the
celestial nowhere before nowhere talks
[ __ ] about arishim's mama or something
and erosion took his head off
foreign
[Music]
Persona music a new massive music
licensing space built by creators or
creators we just started using it this
month and quite honestly we love it
sounds good Persona music offers
unlimited copyright cleared music for
your videos on all platforms under a
single subscription license their
Library features music from Marvel and
Disney trailers and the award-winning
soundtracks and hundreds of hit TV shows
and if you're a Creator Persona music
will make your life so much easier
Persona integrates with YouTube's
Content ID fingerprinting system to
detect and clear claims within minutes
just pop your channel ID and social URLs
in your user dashboard and boom you're
whitelisted all videos published during
your persona subscription will be
cleared from Content ID claims forever
so take bad demonetization you bastard
but if you like our music so much we're
using it all over our Channel now so to
get started with Persona music just head
to
app.personamusic.io or click the link in
the description go to the pricing page
choose your plan sign up and apply code
rockstars25 at checkout to get a 25
discount and one free month of persona
music now I do not think that this was
your ordinary dip in the pool for Dave
Bautista I think that's something about
falling into this vat of celestial DNA
could have changed Drax on a cellular
level possibly even evolving drags and
making him stronger over time which
could have potentially helped him
survive all these crazy things like
crashing into trees and being shot in
that type of celestial intervention
within lower life forms is exactly what
the high evolutionary has always been
about in the comics and I have a feeling
that the drax's celestial biology is
something that the high evolutionary
will be able to suss out just by looking
at tracks due to the high evolutionaries
immense familiarity within the Realms of
evolution much like the hive Priestess
Aisha of the highly evolved Sovereign
race was able to discern Peter Quill's
unique Celestial DNA just by looking at
Adam it even proposed sleeping with him
for further genetic analysis what is
your heritage Mr quill
my mother is from Earth
and your father
aim for Missouri
that's all I know
I see it within you an unorthodox
genealogy
a hybrid that seems particularly
Reckless
so I think there's a good chance here
that both Aisha and the high
evolutionary share this impressive
ability to be able to see people's
genetic potential due to them being the
Supreme experts in their field of
evolution in the entire universe like
there's no one that knows more about
Evolution than the eye evolutionary and
The Sovereign people but either way
drax's contact with Celestial DNA will
probably be the conduit through which
she is kidnapped from the Guardians
prompting the Guardians to need to
rescue Drax for the clutches of the high
evolutionaries experiments which could
be why we see Drax looking a little bit
worse for wear in this shot in the
trailer like this dude literally had a
massive laser in his chest area that for
sure tickled a nipple or two I'll tell
you what those nipples definitely got
tickled
it's so stupid but yeah unfortunately
there's a good chance that Drax yet
another one of Rocket raccoon's friends
will die by the knife of the high
evolutionary's deadly curiosity
prompting Rock of the raccoon to be the
Avenger that Earth made him to be during
all those sad years on Earth an Avengers
Fallen comrades once and for all but
only time will tell cannot wait for this
gosh dang movie it can't wait to cry by
myself because nobody loves me
Thanksgiving
but enough for watching this video you
can follow me at masterton on Twitter
because you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] and then same theories but
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media and of course do not forget to hit
up new accessmerch.com so you can buy
one of our amazing nerd options over
there we have so many cool stuff for you
or someone nerdying your family or your
friend group that you love so buy
something at new roxasmirch.com today
it's a great way to support the channel
but also don't forget to check out our
sponsor of today's video because
checking them out helps the channel out
immensely as well but yes thank you guys
so much again for watching this video I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys later goodbye
foreign
[Music]